okay on tuesday hindenburg research
announced they are launching a bounty
program
to get information on tether
and they've offered up one
million dollars yes on tuesday october
19th the short selling research firm
tweeted the following
we have doubts about the legitimacy of
tether so today
we announce the hindenburg tether bounty
program a reward of up to one million
dollars for details on tethers backing
hindenburg research is offering the
bounty because they want to quote
help advance the public's knowledge of
what it believes is a growing threat to
investors by encouraging disclosures
related to a crucial part of the crypto
markets
which are nearing
systemic size according to the
announcement on their website remember
hindenburg is the short seller who broke
the nikola short report and uh they were
dming us and talking to us when we had
uh the nicola founder on the program
they're similar to scorpion capital uh
who we just covered
and tether initially claimed it was a
stable coin as you know uh and that it
was one to one backed by the us dollar
however then tether admitted that the
coin was only backed by a small tiny
amount of cash and traditional currency
and a significant amount of the backing
consisted of holdings of commercial
paper which are loans and they wouldn't
name the parties and they might be in
china or international who knows but
tether has a 70 billion dollar market
cap that's kind of i think going
sideways it stopped growing uh which is
probably a good thing because 70 billion
dollars is big hole if it were to
collapse or you know half of it were to
go away and they've never done an audit
or provided basic transparency despite
the fact that they say that in response
to hindenburg's announcement teller
followed up with a meme and an official
statement and uh hindenburg called them
out hinderberg's tweet reads in response
to our calls for basic transparency
tether issued a cartoon called a cynical
and suggested that releasing more
information on its backing may discredit
itself
so this is one of the rules i have about
fraud anytime people who are involved in
a fraud and we don't know if tether is a
fraud yet but my god the
different uh sanctions and fines are
starting to mount and the buzz
is obviously troubling
and them responding in this way is a red
flag
when elizabeth holmes and theranos were
accused of wrongdoing what did they do
they attacked a journalist
john carrero from the wall street
journal who's award-winning and his
research and who's reporting is by all
accounts and by all of my observations
bulletproof and extraordinary and so
when you attack the messenger in this
case
uh hindenburg in previous cases they
attacked bloomberg i believe financial
times myself
bitfinex i mean they just attack anybody
who puts up any kind of a question a
reasonable question to them
that is a sign that instead of just
saying hey
that's a reasonable question here's the
answer
they attack them that's a sign that
somebody has something to hide
it's just a classic sociopathic
liar behavior now we don't know if
tether's lying but uh they have been
accused of that based on their fines
here's the quote uh the stunt from
hindenburg research is a pathetic bid
for attention while others are making
real change and building wealth and
results
so again
just obscurifying and attacking the
messenger they are attempting to
discredit not just tether but an entire
movement thankfully everyone sees with
their opportunism as bitcoin approaches
another all-time high
and so basically what tether is doing is
trying to build a whole us versus that
mentality they're trying to build a
group of people
and trying to rally bitcoin when it hits
a high
to defend tether uh and so
we still have never heard from the ceo
uh where is the ceo we invited the ceo
of tether on the program we invited the
ceo of usdc jeremy lair on the program
he was on the program what just
yesterday did a great job explained
everything he said they're going to move
to dollar for dollar they're not going
to try to make this big float on the
dollars and that they're going to
they're going to be public soon like
they're super super
regulated and here in the united states
and obviously tether is banned from
operating in new york and they just had
another uh huge fine the tether
investigation continues uh on this
weekend tether
uh we've had a great time going down the
rabbit hole with this company is it
possible that they're just misunderstood
by the attorney general
canada's regulation boards and their
recent 41 million dollar fine and
hindenburg research and the financial
times and bloomberg yeah sure it's
possible tether is completely
misunderstood and on the up and up but
my lord when i see this many red flags i
just think
where is the department of justice where
is the sec on this i mean
they should be forced uh these stable
coins to have an audit level that is
higher than anything else out there why
these stable coins are replacing the us
dollar
they're designed to replace the us
dollar if they're replacing the us
dollar in people's
you know trading and bank accounts and
and how they're doing commerce in the
world this better be on the up and up i
mean they've basically created their own
currency and people are using it as a
replacement for the us dollar it should
be regulated and arguably should be
taxed and it should be audited it should
have the highest level of scrutiny not
the lowest it should be run by the most
serious and the most ethical
and you know
uh by founders who and ceos who will go
to jail will go to jail if they don't do
it properly jeremiah kind of understood
that he's like yeah we're gonna go to
jail basically if we don't do this right
well i think if the tether ceo is
you know with logan roy in croatia
wherever he went on the first episode of
secession on sunday like i i'm wondering
if the tether executives are currently
in a place where they don't extradite
people i'm wondering uh yeah and ripple
that's another one xrp don't get me
started
if you listen to twist often you've
heard me talk about odoo's suite of
business apps a lot and they are sweet
well they're going to give you your
first app free forever and a thousand
dollars off your implementation pack at
odoo.com twist odo.com twist and here is
why odoo is amazing for startups their
suite of business apps helps you run
your entire company on one platform and
they will streamline the workflows by
bringing all your information together
eliminating annoying repetitive tasks
like entering data across multiple
platforms plus if you only need two or
three apps to optimize your workflow at
your startup well that's all you'll pay
for they're not going to charge you for
apps you don't use of course not
and odoo offers 30 main apps that are
gonna get almost everything in your
organization done plus 16 000 apps from
their open source community for those
niche applications that might be unique
to your business their apps include
bookkeeping sales crm website builders
and more so here is your cta the old
call to action again your first app is
free forever and oh do is offering one
thousand dollars right now on your first
implementation pack get that credit
right now before it's gone odo.com
twist